[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كل وسائل الترفيه دي وان انا دايما بنسعى
اننا نكون فرحانين ومبسوطين في حياتنا ليه
الناس لسه حزينه او مكتئبه او ممكن تكون
بتفكر في الانتحار
ده بسبب ان احنا ما نتخلصش من المشاعر
السلبيه اللي بتكون ناتجه من تعرضنا
لمواقف مؤلمه في حياتنا زي انك مثلا تفقد
شخص عزيز عليك او انك يحصل لك صعوبات في
الحياه او تتعرض للخزان من اي حد كان قريب
عليك
المواقف دي بتفضل تتراكم جوانا
ممكن تسبب لك
تحس بعدها مش قادر تتحرك مش حاسس ان في
معنى في حياتك مش قادر تكمل حياتك من غير
الناس دي بس ما تقلقش انت مش لوحدك حتى
انا الحياه فرقتني على الناس كنت بحبها
ااا وحطيته في مواقف ونوقف دي كل ما
بفتكرها
بتسيب جوايا علامه بتوجعني دايما
بس جيت مره حد رشح لي كتاب اسمه
او سماح بالرحيل لدكتور ديفيد موفي الكتاب
ده بيشرح نظريه اللي هي بتقول او معناها
انقطاع مفاجئ لضغط داخلي
بتحس بعده
بشعور الراحه والسعاده اللي مكتوب بالحريه
بتحس بشعور الراحه الموجود بالحريه بس فهو
بيجي يلخص لك في الكتاب ده انك ازاي
تتعامل مع مشاعرك وازاي تتخلص من المشاعر
السلبيه دي لحد لما توصل انك تحس بشعور
الراحه ده بس قبل ما اشرح لك ازاي تتخلص
من مشاعرك بشرحلك ازاي تفهم مشاعرك وتقرا
نفسك بطريقه صح الاول كل واحد فينا
بيتعامل مع مشاعره بثلاث طرق ااا 90% من
الناس اللي قاعدين بياخدوا الطريقه الاولى
دي في الحضن اللي هو انا كنت اولكم اللي
هو انت زعلان لا لا انت مش زعلان لا انا
بقول لك انت مش زعلان احنا زي الفل
الطريقه الاولى دي اسمها القمع او الكبت
هنا انت بتخفي مشاعرك وما بتواجههاش خالص
الحاجه الثانيه اللي صدمتني مع الكتاب انك
لما
اتكلم عن اللي جواك هتعرف تتخطاه اا عبر
عن مشاعرك عشان تنساها الموضوع ده كله ده
طلع غلط الدراسات والابحاث اثبتت انك لما
تتكلم عن شعورك المؤلم بالنسبه لك انت كده
بتعمقه جواك ااا
وممكن كمان طول التجربه السيئه دي للشخص
اللي قدامك فيحس بنفس الشعور وهو ما مرش
بالموضوع ده الطريقه دي اسمها التعبير اما
الطريقه الثالثه فهي الهروب ودي بتكون
باستخدام والهلال زي انك مثلا تلجا لل
1000 او الاجمال او المخدرات او ممكن حاجه
بسيطه لو هتقول انا مثلا ااا اروح اشوف
الفيلم وهبقى تمام او اروح ادخل يا عم على
انغامي اسمعني شويه اغاني وخلاص وهخرج من
المود وابقى
الثلاث طرق دول
بتخزن المشاعر السلبيه جوانا وفي ناس غصب
عنها ما بتعرفش تطلع من المشاعر دي لانها
على مدار حياتنا اتعرضنا
زرعت جوانا الخوف ده
موقف دي
كانت
كفيله ان هي تخلينا كل مره يتعرض موقف
جديد نحس الشعور اللي فات ونطلعه تخيل
معايا في حد متعود على الفراق والخزلان من
صغره لو جيت من وهو صغير كان ما كانش
الطفل المميز عند اهله
بين صحابه ما كانش في حد بيخسرني لو جيت
دخل الترفيهي واترفض شعوره هيكون ايه في
اللحظه دي او لو مثلا حب حد والحب ده طلع
من طرف واحد هيحس ايه في اللحظه دي اكيد
انا حاسس ان هو متدمر او مبسوط او ان هو
حتى مش قادر يكمل حياتي ممكن يقرر يقفل
على نفسه للابد طب هل رد فعله ده كله بسبب
الموقف الصغير اللي هو اتعرض ده الاجابه
لا الشخص ده على مدار حياتي
اتحط في مواقف كثير عم الاحساس ده جواه
الموقف الصغير ده كان بمثابه الشراره ان
هو يطلع عقله الباطن اختار الناس للغلط
اللي ما لهوش اي ذنب باللي حصل علشان يطلع
عليهم
الشعور اللي كان جوايا ويلعبوا ادوار مش
ادورهم
الشعور هو مشتق تراكمي من الافكار فده
معناه ان مش الافكار هي اللي تؤلمنا لكن
الشعور المختفي وراء الافكار دي فعشان
توضح لنا الموضوع ده حطلنا مقياس اسمه
مقياس الوعي اللي بيقسم الافكار لتلات
مناطق اول حاجه المعتصاد سلبيه ودي بتتدرج
من العار لحد الاسد لا
المنطقه دي هي بتمثل اول حاجه بتحس بيها
او ما يحصلك موقف مؤلم بعدين المنطقه
الانتقاليه دي رد الفعل عن مشاعر السلبيه
واللي هي بتكون من اول الخوف لحد
الاستعداد بعدين المنطقه الايجابيه وده
اللي احنا بنسعاه ان احنا نوصل له بعد اي
موقف سلبي او مؤلم بالنسبه لنا اتحطينا
فيكم تمام
تخيل معايا بس عشان تفهم الموضوع ده
وتدرج الاشاعه لو انت مثلا حط في دماغك
دلوقتي فكره انك خايف
اشخاص معينه او اصحابك يتخلوا عنك اقنع
دماغك ان هم اوريدي يتخلوا عنك خلاص
هتبدا تحس بايه اول حاجه ممكن تحس مثلا
انك مشاعر الحزن من اللي حصل ده بتمثلوا
المنطقه السلبيه بعدين لو انت في الموقف
ده رد فعلك على ان هم تخلوا عنك هيكون ايه
ممكن تحس بالخوف الخوف من اللي حصل برده
او انك هتواكله ازاي ممكن تحس بالشجاعه
الشجاعه اللي هتقول لك انك لازم تموتني
خزان الاحزان دلوقتي مفيش وقت بعدين ممكن
بعدها خلاص اتحررت من الشعور ده لحد لما
توصل للمنطقه الايجابيه اللي هي هتقول لك
انك لازم تكون متقبل الوضع راضي عنها تشوف
حياتك
خلاص انت مش هينفع تفضل مركز مع الناس دي
لازم تنفقون على طول
هتقول لي طب ماشي ده موقف خالي انا بقى لو
جيت موقف حصل دلوقتي في الحقيقه المفروض
اعمل ايه
النظريه دي بتقول لك انك لازم تعيش الشعور
زي ما هو تقبله ما تهربش منه ما تحاولش
انك تواجهه او تخاف منه ما تعملش معه
بمنطقيه يعني انك مثلا ما تسالش انا ليه
حصل معايا ده طب اشمعنى اتجاهل اي افكار
بتجيلك بخصوص الشعور ده يعني لو جاء في
دماغك انك تهرب منه لا انا لازم اوجه نفسي
انا لازم اقعد مع نفسي كل يوم افكر انا لا
انا مش هينفع افضل كده لازم اموت فون من
الموضوع ما تحطلوش وقت يعني انت
ما تقولش انا
كل مشاعري لا انت سيبها هي تاخذ وقتها
براحتها لحد لما تطلع منك خالص ما تسمعش
لاي حد يقول لك انك اوفر او انك موقوع
ونكبره لا انت بس تقدر تقول ده لو المشاعر
بتاعتك دي كانت سببها لسه موجود هتعمل
حاجه اسمها معالجه للماضي معالجه الماضي
دي انك تفكر
الشعور ده
ايه نتائجه الحلوه والوحشه عليك في وقتها
تمام
هل انت اتعلمت الدرس هل الموقف ده خلاك
انضج طب هل انت الموقف اللي حصل ده يستاهل
انك تضيع المستقبل في انك تفضل تفكر في
حاجات من الماضي اصلا لا
ركز على شعورك واعترف بيها خصص وقت
للتفكير لو انت مثلا مش فاضي حاول حتى كل
اسبوع تقعد ساعه مع نفسك تفكر في اي طاقه
سلبيه هتسيب بها على مدار الاسبوع بتخليك
مش قادر تتعامل او تكمل
لازم لحد لما توصل لمرحله التسليم التسليم
دي انك هتحس ان خلاص انت اسقطت كل اللي
عليك وكل الشعور اللي عليك احس انك حر في
حياتنا كان في مشاعر كتير احنا اتخلصنا
منها بشكل غير واعي
كانت زمان ممكن تكون بتؤلمنا لكن دلوقتي
ممكن ما اكونش فاكرينها اصلا
على العكس في مشاعر ثاني احنا لسه ما
خلصناش منها يعني مستنيه بس الشراره ان هي
تطلع علشان هي الستل موجوده احنا ما
واجهناش اصلا بس دورك دلوقتي انك تختار
الشعور تواجهه لما اعرف انك مهما وقعت
هتقوم زي ما انا وقعت عند السلم هنا
دلوقتي عادي وقمت عشان ادي التوم يعني
عادي خالص بس همم كل حد فينا هيقع ويقوم
ااا هيعرف يكمل من غير الناس اللي هم
سابوهم وهيعرف يتخطى كل الشعور ده لانه
كانت ستارز شابتر اف يو
بس شكرا
[تصفيق]